[Musik]
sebastian lee gezeigt was wirklich
hinter dem ersatzstoff xylit steckt im
supermarkt wird er als gesunde
kalorienarme brücken zuckerverkauf
sebastian weiß wieviel birke wirklich
drin steckt so viele schöne süße sachen
aber wie wir wissen es und wir deutschen
zu viel zucker 90 gramm pro kopf pro tag
die industrie kennt das schlechte
gewissen der kunden und reagiert darauf
mit diversen zucker alternativen und das
sind längst nicht mehr nur die üblichen
süßstoffe der neueste trend bitten
zucker auch xylit genannt im vergleich
zum haushaltszucker hat er 40 prozent
weniger kalorien ist genauso süß kostet
aber bis zu 22 mal so viel
lohnt sich der preis
[Musik]
in seiner werkstatt zeigt uns
produktentwickler sebastian lege was
wirklich im wirken zucker steckt und
startet mit einer überraschung anders
als der name vermuten lässt dient keine
birke als rohstoff sondern hat der
kleine hase die kölner schon abgehakt
und der erste schritt ist lang wie
willem aus dem mais abfall birken zucker
zunächst muss läge die harten kolben
auskochen bisschen wie popcorn klever
hier durch das kochen lösen sich
substanzen aus dem inneren der strecke
darunter auch der rohstoff xylose der
lässt sich anschließend in das begehrte
xylit verwandeln
[Applaus]
brice lecker nach mais ist das mit
birken zucker zu tun hat tatsächlich
kommt xylit in unterschiedlichen
pflanzen vor vor allem in den bergen
wäldern skandinaviens versteckt in der
baumrinde
daher auch der name würden zucker doch
die xylit gewinnung aus birken ist teuer
deshalb setzen die chemiker der
industrie auf billigere quellen
denn das gleiche resultat lässt sich
auch mit psychose aus mais abfall
erzielen
auch andere materialien lassen sich
prinzipiell nutzen
neben mais etwa buchenholz späne oder
reste die bei der papierherstellung
anfallen
[Musik]
da wirken zucker nur ein
umgangssprachlicher begriff ist darf er
auch auf der verpackung stehen
selbst dann wenn das produkt gar nichts
mitbürger zu tun hat gut für den handel
denn im gegensatz zu xylit klingt wirken
zucker doch viel gesünder und weniger
nach chemie
[Musik]
inzwischen kommt sebastian dem
zuckerersatz den man eher mit hilfe
einer obstpresse quetscht er die
gekochten maiskolben aus der saft
enthält schon eine menge xylose
[Musik]
das müsse reichen und unsere basis
doch noch hat lege ein problem xylose
ist zwar auch schon eine art zucker doch
im vergleich zum gewünschten endprodukt
nur halb so süß und genau auf die füße
kommt es schließlich an
deshalb haben chemiker einen trick
entwickelt mit dem sie den saft süßer
machen
[Musik]
hefe aber keine normale hilfe die man
auch nicht einfach so im laden um die
ecke kaufen kann eine ganz spezielle
industrie hilfe diese industrie häfen
wurden eigens dafür gezüchtet dass
xylose molekül zu schlucken und ein
wenig umzubauen kleine lebende
chemiefabriken sie produzieren als
abfallprodukt das zuckersüße xylit für
unsere zungen ist es genau so süß wie
echte haushaltszucker
hat aber 40 prozent weniger kalorien
dieses industrie xylit gilt als
chemische substanz und wird bei
lebensmitteln als zusatzstoff 967
ausgewiesen
[Musik]
jetzt ist meint litt schon so gut wie
fertig muss nur noch mit der
zentrifugalkraft gereinigt werden so
dass sich dem puren rohstoffe erhalten
zu guter letzt trend lege alle unnützen
schwebstoffe in sirup vom reinen xylit
alles was ich oben absetzt kommt weg
übrig bleibt nur ein klarer seiner
koalition
hier habe ich ein backblech damit
sebastian zuckerersatz so schön körnig
wird wie normaler streue zucker muss er
jetzt noch schonend getrocknet werden
[Musik]
im umluft herz kristallisiert der birken
zucker innerhalb von acht stunden aus
richtig schön trocken geworden sieht das
so aus wie eine kleine schlittschuhbahn
experiment geglückt jetzt damit xii
kristalle rieseln wie echter zocker muss
sebastian die brocken nur noch
zerbröseln
[Musik]
da es unser birken zucker sind optisch
nah dran am echten zucker doch kann die
alternative auch geschmacklich mithalten
und gleichzeitig unsere kalorien
probleme lösen
im supermarkt machen wir den test ohne
zu wissen worum es geht hier kosten die
kunden xylit und haushaltszucker merken
sie den unterschied für seine schmecken
auch so man merkt es ist kein zucken
aber es kommt dann kommt so ein bisschen
so ein pelz auf der zunge hinterlässt
sind die beide gleich bei der süßkraft
kann die alternative mit zucker
mithalten
und anders als zucker verursacht solid
keine karies
es soll sogar davor schützen deshalb
steckt es in zahncremes und bonbons doch
zahn schonend heißt nicht figur schonend
[Musik]
das täuscht plötzlich unseren kopf nur
vor dass wird der zucker konsumiert
hätten deswegen beschreiben auch viele
patienten nach dem konsum von süßstoffen
oder zucker alkohol dass der appetit
danach nicht wirklich weg geht das
sozusagen das bedürfnis zum essen weiter
aufrecht erhalten ist
hinzu kommt noch ein weiterer nachteil
wirken zucker bekommt nicht jedem so
dass viele menschen diesen
zuckerersatzstoff nicht gut vertragen
dass sie verdauungsprobleme bekommen
seines blähungen durchfall oder andere
nebenwirkungen die vielleicht auch nicht
besonders schön sind
unser zucker problem löst xylit also nur
begrenzt positiv der zorn schonende
effekt doch beim abnehmen hilft der
teure sogar satz nur wenig und er kann
unangenehme nebenwirkungen hervorrufen
muss es immer echter zucker sein oder
greift er auch mal zu einer alternative
sagt es uns in den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mal über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert df besser
esser und schaut den die nächsten zwei
clips
[Musik]